well yesterday we told you about a mass
illness at a Southwest Valley elementary
school today parents say they still
don't know what happened yeah this all
happened at Wayne and Tanaka Elementary
reportedly infecting over a hundred
students last week the school is near
Fort Apache and Warm Springs Ryan mathey
reached out to the school and the health
district trying to get some answers for
these families on what upset all these
kids stomachs Ryan yeah Brian Denise in
my hand right here these are just some
of the emails that eight news now
investigators and I have sent to CCSD
over the past three days our sources say
roughly 130 students were intensely
vomiting during school on Friday but it
seemingly wasn't kept in the classroom
as some of their families report
catching it too
at the end of the day we don't know
what's going on we don't know how to
help them I mean if kids are a priority
then we need to know what's going on so
we can help our children Joyce as she
wants to be called to preserve her
identity says her nine-year-old daughter
came home from Tanaka Elementary
Thursday just fine it wasn't until
overnight while she was sleeping she
started having a stomach ache and then
she threw up about five to six times
overnight the mother says she kept her
daughter home on Friday the day of the
reported Mass vomiting and a day later
she showed symptoms
she shares several other parent
speculations that contaminated cafeteria
food on Thursday was the source the
Southern Nevada Health District telling
8 news now that gastrointestinal viruses
are commonly spread by eating drinking
or touching contaminated food or
surfaces but when we asked the school
district multiple times if that's the
suspected cause CCSD sent this the same
email to parents from Friday that
advised of a health district
investigation Joyce says her daughter
ate the cafeteria food on Thursday and
days later this mother continues to feel
shut out about what potentially left her
and her fourth grader sick I don't know
if they have have all the information
present as to what happened but I wish
that we did have more constant updates
as to what's going on what it was
now I have many questions like these
parents do that we sent to the School's
district such as how many were ill how
many were sent home on Friday we're
still awaiting those answers but the
school district they did respond partly
today they said the school did undergo
deep cleaning on Friday and that
generally speaking sick people should
not prepare or handle food Brian all
right Ryan I'll take it from here thanks
for that the Southern Nevada Health
District tells the Ryan that it doesn't
have specifics to report just yet but
during a foodborne illness outbreak
quote people are interviewed about what
they ate before they got sick when
possible food contamination is confirmed
using epidem epidemiological and
laboratory information